[Music]
see that that's how dumb this game will
get you'll get voted out for stuff like
that
and it literally like there was nothing
you could have done
so yeah you calling me to that yeah you
call the meeting if
if you see something you don't like
because the only other way to do is if
you have a dead body
all right we know it's kid's moves so
let's roll mate damn it
hey i'm gonna fall you can hear this are
you hearing you crossed
oh my bad so just vote for yourself kid
i can't vote
okay i can't wait till we still have to
if they force you to type
no no no no no no did that that's chat
for
like back out of it no no you gotta wear
it down you have to wait for a certain
amount of time before gotcha
oh okay
on february
are you serious discord doing that
foolishness again yeah yeah let's go
ahead and even come back in
all right yeah i can't hear luke
well i can't i haven't heard luca but
can you hear me addict or no yeah i can
hear you
all right yeah i had to mess with some
settings too that's why i didn't jump in
earlier
go ahead and uh set up um
death where they can't see who's voting
yeah yeah make the visuals off oh i mean
you've already done it i can see it
i'm making the game now should we just
kiss stick now let's not stick with this
stick with the standard map
yeah stick with the standard map i don't
want nothing complicated
the other maps aren't complicated it
just can get complicated
like really fast
all right game okay is there any way to
adjust the volume
i launched the game and when you launch
the game that's like
okay at the volume yeah just to find
among us and turn it down
appreciate that hello good
that's right kill cool down 35 yeah
she's there somewhere
until she's there so she's probably
waking up
she probably got some coffee in her hand
or something
two coming to ask one long no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no 35 too
long
i could do like 30 do like 30.
kill this short yes imposter vision
have you tried that uh brexavity chat um
jack
it's where people can uh there's a game
chat and
a certain for a certain area around you
no i i never do that i see people online
using like that for the like
killers to talk to each other and [ __ ]
what a big discussion of voting time
yeah that's fine what was that invite
how you
send me the invite so i can give it to
get the recording king all right that
looks good
all right yeah i'll send the information
i'll
you probably have to just tell them the
code down there at the bottom
all right yeah i'll do it that way
yep are you posting in
uh general chat
you might have to do it again because he
got invited afterwards
oh yeah yeah yeah
there we go codes up i typed in again
where you typed it in general yeah okay
what's up hustle appreciate it man i
appreciate it
oh you got the stream papa see
all right j dubs up oh cool
i thought nude is like well i can't
really say much because sometimes i'll
be waking up at 2 pm
sometimes i do be waking up late you're
yeah yeah that's that young life cognito
exactly that's that great shift
addict was like moot you up like up
[Laughter]
nasty you guys deserve it you live in
new jersey
[Laughter]
you bout to get some of that
when did you get hit last night yeah
yeah it started like what time it
started like
maybe seven eight like seven eight pm
and it just kept going
it looked like it was gonna be light but
it just kept going it just stopped like
a minute ago right
yeah yeah it's already sunny here yeah
here too
that's what's up i think i think the
wind shifted it
all right look at you there
hey let me move here and move her back
in maybe she's
last time like we're not everyone is not
watching stream naturally
and then we mute up yeah yeah yeah that
that's the rules that's how we're doing
you just mute when you
uh when you're not uh when and when it's
not during your discussion phase you
mute
and when you're dead you mute yeah when
you're dead you meet too oh yeah i
forgot cognito if you die you have to
mute your mic
i can't snitch no you can't snitch
but you could talk in the chat to other
dead people okay
so mute only when um what'd you call it
just keep your mic muted unless
uh unless um we're on the little thing
where it's discussed
yeah yeah okay
let me send luca a message maybe maybe
she she
if if if you think you're talking to us
look you're not
maybe your mic's messed up yeah
daniel said whoever could be the most
deceiving i'm eager to fight
hustler motivate what's going on that's
crazy
they can hit a discord oh no yeah they
could they they should be able to get
the discord
you guys can hear the discord right
yeah he got it here because racy was
talking about he must have heard me talk
about new york city snow
i mean mooch was talking booty time said
come on man dude it's noon
do you guys hear everyone fine we're
waiting for people
to wake up i heard yeah
i heard uh singer i've heard
addict incognito i haven't heard jack
yet well jack's there i've heard jack
yeah i haven't heard luca or luca or
well smoove's muted so what was beauty
now but i've heard luka say she's gonna
do to do
king sounded all the way in the bushes
bro
[Laughter]
like he had death in his throat you know
you're just getting the crushed out shot
yeah all right
are we ready yet or no we're waiting for
everyone to get in
you sent the invo death oh hold up that
started a whole new one
um yeah because i have to change the
sentence
is it in the to the general chat yeah
yeah oh yeah
there's the invite code is in the
general chat
oh cognito how many hours you got in
this game
this game yeah 10 minutes
okay so i'm at like a half hour so we're
good
you can tell by the questions you're
asking i'm like i'm glad he's asking you
coffee
how do i get hold on i have to find a
way
how do i leave game
and go to find a match create a game
private
code all right i have 82 hours in this
game somehow
holy [ __ ] how do i check oh there we go
steam
[Music]
hey you want to reset it real quick
someone just owned up to being the
imposter
if you only got one plot for all two um
i put two on maybe that's because there
isn't enough people for two so we
automatically
i don't think it matters well it did
because when there was four of us i had
two on
and it already gave us one
let's do it automatically oh what did
you say luka
i still can't hear luca i can't hear
luca i heard her for a second
hey y'all streaming on the iron arts
channel
[Music]
king should be here pretty soon and jade
let me know when you guys are done
oh there there she is yeah there she
goes
i gotta turn up this is a practice run
really i mean this is what
this is a practice room oh okay because
death
started we supposed to be muted anyway
right
yeah yeah oh someone's dead
oh someone cat mooch
i think it's jack because he ain't
talking nope
because jack was with me in engineering
then kiss me so he's self-stitching i
don't know i don't trust you death i i
never trust you
it's smooth it's smooth it's smooth
[Music]
why would it be me jack let's
let's get death up out of here i'm
voting death
yeah no it's gotta be addictive smooth
there's no way
i could have clapped jack otherwise
i was
i was messing with my settings i have no
idea who even killed me he looked up and
the screen went
red yeah came here
man what's up yo yo what up
these dudes man
i also don't like the way some of you
dudes moving
uh
uh yeah i got tossed for no reason none
at all i get tossed because
i called out the correct person watch it
end up being dead singer
i don't know i think he actually might
be doing
a scan it might be kid smooth
yeah it's kid smooth he he just chill
yeah his kid's
he's gonna come out right here nope
i don't know but you killed him on
camera and then reported it
who reported it you i thought you i
literally saw you do it
how did that report i didn't even
remember all right we're going
to highlight we're all late bro
it was a good run no but i didn't report
anything though
you can't be killing people on camera
like that you definitely reported nah i
do
not bro like i wasn't like
but how did that rep i didn't report
anything
okay okay actually crazy bro
i i i regret defending smooth
[Music]
all right jd hey reporting
you should have just fell on the sword
let him fall on it
i will send the code to both of you
individually
king should be here mateo
here's yours luca and jado
do i need to send it to king 2 yeah i
would send it to him
whoa
damn what
who was in the in among us
his name kind of crazy is that a random
person
already with this nonsense someone
kicking
wow how do i kick someone
i can't remember it don't kick him it's
like it's like it's like a little boot
at the top
jack you just just just go start another
one so i can
hide this little thing on my screen oh
yeah oh you showed it on stream
i forgot oh that's what you did hold on
as soon as you show down streams i
forgot all right
i forgot get off my back
so we accidentally
i'ma have to hide the little the little
number in the middle
i gotta leave and then okay then i'm
gonna hit the button now
there we go yeah yeah yeah we're glad we
lit
how do you lead um wrench at the upper
right
and then you should see those options
come up
all right let me send the new code to
people because
why is your eye going on the stream
though because i because the code's
there i had to cover the
oh yeah
oh there's luca
no way that's not look good
yeah that's me
she's like just something look who would
have her name
and the look the look i do
what's your youtube handle youtube
handle okay
yeah it's just getting okay
you're streaming yeah
that's not no it's definitely on the
iron lord's podcast
channel no no i'm asking because i'm
trying to
send a chat but it's not tagging it's
not doing auto tag
my my twitter handle no your youtube you
know how you have to add
and then put in
it's just gaming and it doesn't matter
if there's a space right
or i don't believe so youtube handles
the space
no space you could you could put a space
in right
jw there
i oh him earlier but he looked like he's
dying oh this what you call it remember
this you in cognition i don't know if he
got permission maybe
no the cognition's open oh god
oh yeah you're the one that's locked
yeah mine's the only one to slog
this world and no one else's
someone's doing an instagram video or
youtube video or else
really yeah it's addict's birthday yes
birthday stream old bastard i don't know
see i prefer people to call me old and
acting like i'm 18. all right
oh my god
coming in the back door you just hold
the back door open
shout out to kid smooth for the 10 super
chat
yes sir we ain't know king and
jay dub jay king might be the bushes let
me see what's going on let me know if
you let me know you want to start
here oh he said four minutes ago coming
okay
okay so he's coming the king will enter
the room
oh lord he's calling me this is he doing
he's probably
having a hard time getting on here
yep he calling
yo they are waiting for you
all right cool you see it so we in the
um the joint the the cognition
voice chat
or the cognition
yeah so when you see at the top you just
click it
tell him he can join any of them and
i'll drag him
you got a anyone jack move that's not
like crazy crazy that can join us i'd
like to have tim
[Music]
raise me oh no did you hear me
hold on
by the way
you really get disgusted with this stuff
don't you
i think it's disgusting i know he's
funny it's stained
yeah all right cool so yeah just launch
up just uh look
whatever just be looking for a person uh
jack move while he gets in here if you
can find one
appreciate it yeah no no not jobs dog no
nothing yeah
i said no no that's all that's all i
know
look there's a difference between nut
jobs and bad [ __ ] crazy all right
like all right so okay the rule they
doing is was it it's beaut
they keep it they sell beauty the whole
joint so yeah they might click on your
name
and then you so nobody extension on
nobody
and then only during the discussion
phase they could they could talk
you catch off on it really really fast
there's only like well well the dead
well the person who got killed can't
talk
right during that time you get murdered
you got to be
yeah you muted the rest of time because
dead people don't talk
you tried hit that blaze blazers
let's go we can't get in here
it's forte we're down yeah four days at
work
i don't hate number one you see him well
there you go i'm gonna meet her
alright cool yeah you fired up you fight
it up i'm i'm
all you gotta do is fire it up and then
i'll tell you how to enter the code so
you can join the game
senator you could jump on here if you
want
oh yeah get sin in here
i don't know man sinister will be on
some it was addict every time
i already know enough of that in jackpot
that's jackpot jackman
people literally blame me for everything
it do be you though
[Music]
oh we got jay there he is
there's the code okay
sin is s plus a destiny but i wonder how
good he is
there you go we got ten you got that now
two is good
oh what's up sinister did you even have
this downloaded
should i ask that but the same you got
it no i don't i don't have it download
it no
it's just it's just it takes like it's
like 50
it's like 50 megabytes i'm launching
steam now i'm launching steel now
cool oh man sam
i'm bored you can't blame me for just
nothing all right you can't do that
attic i saw him i saw him he actually it
was him
he said i'm going to be making it see
how this is going to go today
you're going to have to leave that chat
too i ain't going to have you stream
sniping
knowing it's me
i can't be the only reason i know y'all
were on was when i was cooking
i saw the message saying that they were
playing well that's 10 people once jw
can't get in here among stewie
mr cheese who is that
mr cheese
isn't it
i assume it's jade though that's got to
be yeah that's me
[Laughter]
out of everything you could have popped
up in here with it
mr cheese was the last thing i thought
you would be in here with
that's
[Laughter]
mr cheese you want some crackers with
that cheese
i was expecting him to cover with a name
like tools or something
[Laughter]
oh
i'm working on it right now
it's sad i had to put what auntie boy
told you happy birthday
yeah i appreciate it pretty i ain't
really trying to get the shot i'm trying
to get the the guy happy birthday
also reach out to eric it's also his
birthday
yeah both of you you and uh follow god
have the same birthday that's good
mm-hmm i gotta update my package
yeah yeah i verified my damn signature
man
let's go all right it's
my code is not working anymore yeah it's
because uh it was a new one click click
the button in the discord yeah
yeah exactly here i'll send it to you on
uh
oh that downloaded instantaneously i
told you it's not that big of a game
yeah so online oh wait wait wait wait
wait we probably wanna
you go set up the character no all you
need is just you put your name because
they won't let you join with the name
and go to general chat and click the the
link
tools i'm done he did it
crazy no that was me oh that was your
yeah he can't name himself what he
normally names himself
how do you name yourself though it's at
the top
on the title page on the top yeah
this is ridiculous man this is really
ridiculous
all right how do i find uh you just
click go
to the general chat and click to join
on discord yeah
now we're just waiting for king dang
that sucks
general chat all right free to play
games purchase
games just enter name type
who's j is that you
it's gotta be j no that's me let me back
out and fix that
what's up megatron
i'm dirty
not seen i like that
y'all want to run it on or wait yes go
and run it while we wait for king to
figure
out
you need any help king
just hit me up on facebook if you need
anything
i saw jw vent oh we supposed to be muted
mute yourself okay hold on
how do i do that right click
oh it's just right clicking game
look at the among us mini hamster
version
um
somebody dead in communications yeah it
said okay
supposed to talk a lot of ways
oh man
i
i didn't say anything somebody came from
their way you know
i'm scared i kind of low-key think it's
sin
but we ain't gonna go into that try to
mute it
not then oh yeah i can't show my screen
all right just get your who got thrown
in the bushes
no one don't know what's going on okay
just me and
all right back to you y'all back to view
mute
mute okay there we go
oh
[Music]
all right
you got anything to say about that
sister you should just go live
luca's just going to be like i thought i
saw this person
that's it i'm voting her now she just
lied i'm voting soon
what's her name is it siddell
it's cecetiah
[Music]
oh wow would you say uh
mute i'm talking to king you're going to
stop that what'd you say king
victory
this is hilarious
i said i couldn't that private culture
gave me no good
you have to wait till this game's over
[Music]
it's luca it's luca look who's up there
with that dead body she tried to
she tried she tried to self-report but
it was too late
get luca up out of here don't listen to
anything this woman's about to say
i don't know she got the last person she
yeah she got me
out no don't listen she
don't let this girl get away with
fixing the lights with smooth and then i
went up and i saw the body and
replicated
oh geez yeah you know what i like lucas
using my tactics i like that he just
starts screaming at the end of the match
i don't know i'm telling you right now
if you mooch if you vote me you have
failed this world
[Music]
all right congratulations you guys are
ridiculous
i don't know who it is
me
somebody's being real spooky
all right now let's get luca up out of
here i'm telling you it is
luca continue lucas uh
it's not how do we how do we even think
it's luca because i saw her kill him
i saw her over that dead body you saw me
over the dead body you didn't see me
kill anybody because i didn't
it's
in that vent room man she vented in
there she killed him
do all that adam keeps making me think
look okay look look jack
look this is this is my proposition to
you guys luca out of here and the game
doesn't end then vote me
vote me
the thing is though that's hard to
explain though when i was working on it
if luke was damn possible i don't think
she would have got another old buddy out
no but
but no matter
and all that jack jack jack you know i'm
always extra in this game
it is good i never
100 i put my humongous name that if you
vote off the island it will end the game
will end
y'all vote and then
attic only has three to kill okay
i don't know why he's accusing me so
hard when i didn't do anything i wasn't
venting or
any of that move i was in the room with
you fixing the lights so it's kind of
weird that you're accusing me it makes
me
i'm not accusing you it's just that you
can try to blame
everyone okay you know what if vote me
out and then when you're wrong i want an
apology
go ahead go ahead don't let this work
man
no go ahead go ahead it's fine this is
going to go lower i'll think
i don't think it's luca yeah vote luca i
don't think i don't think it's luca
either
luca can't
i'm gonna get voted okay okay
thank god
oh no oh
luke i'm sorry for them i ain't she's
looking suspect
uh
running out of oxygen
it was mooch wow
look okay first off look i apologize
luca look at you look at that listen
listen luca look
you gotta admit
you said i saw you over the dead body i
saw you you were over the dead boy
no no you said i saw you over the dead
body i saw you kill him
i saw you vent you said all envelopes
none of that were true
where's the apology i apologize you
weren't the imposter yeah
look look jack if you go up in the if
you go up in the electrical you see it
does someone over a dead body what you
thinking
no man that was kind of crazy though you
like it's not over
i was convinced we were just so quick
because you was over a dead body i was
the one who reported
literally followed me in the middle of
nowhere and i could kill him and there
was no one around i vented and
just disappeared that body wasn't found
for a half hour yo your goomba
came out on that bush
which played it really well he's like
yeah i don't think it's luca okay
mute
unmute for discussion not saying it's
sinister it's just sinister was in the
room with the dead body and didn't
report it
i was i didn't even know i was next to
addict
you were next to addict i was in a bit
by wires some wires
was around sin i didn't
did you see me did i see you no i didn't
see you
so how you gonna say it was me sitters
just take the l
like stop trying to don't leave me okay
here we go
all i know is attic was right behind me
and he went into the corner where water
just take that okay go ahead yeah i got
to vote you just because you could
i need an apology when it's over too a
funny sound i'm not i'm not voting
where he moves like i said i i just saw
him i'm not sure if it was him or
not so this man goes sit here and try
you know i don't uh
i don't want another situation like
you're the only person
i don't know anything else i'm trying to
figure out wires
and then you walk past me
go up in the bushes i didn't even see
this just don't vote or vote you
sinister
adam you can hear yeah i can hear sin i
can't hear him
you're not dead sin you you're good i
think i think you you you muted him in
discord you got to unmute him yeah
i didn't mute him in discord no i'm
talking about
magneto he's good
right you can mute people individually
you can mute people yourself you know i
mean so
yeah i just muted off my my button
no you're right jack that's my bad i'm
muted in my mistake
is
uh
uh
i found a green body at the
at the bottom of the map i don't know
where this is called yeah
but they got mooching
are you gonna do me like that
people so was it like at the bottom like
the middle bottom
like the left bottom i don't know i'm
just learning this game but it's at the
bottom
okay the bottom of the map did anyone
else see anything anyone else
this is hard to play with you on my lap
baby you got to go get a chair
i see it i see i didn't see anything i
didn't see anything no
i didn't i didn't see anything but i'm
just recording that
the o2 on the right but by the time i
went to the right it was already done so
someone else was over there
so how do you spit you just go to the
bottom left and i'll say
oh just vote okay
is cradles even here
sinister yeah you are an imposter fan
stop it i'm you're supposed to kill
people you're not supposed to report
dead bodies and stuff
i dragged you to another one say that
you accidentally lagged out when i tend
to send you back okay
just connected yeah i guess discord
discord's messing up cause
i was i got lagged out and i locked back
in nope
all right back on mute yeah
oh
i just saw it on camera caught on my
screen i know who one of them is this
addict
why is it always me no he wasn't i just
saw him on the couch
i just saw you
right now who would you see him kill
them kill them hold on i do want to
point out
that when um we had the first round and
attic was like oh it's sinister get him
out of here and then the second round
attic didn't say anything about sinister
trying to vote him out it's kind of
weird considering how vehement
he was to get me out of here off of
nothing so he was over a dead body
i am look i don't know what is your
problem with me death but i'm not liking
it i'm not
i witnessed you chopped my mancognito in
half
damn it might actually be sinister hold
[Music]
on
that was that was unfortunate you guys
that that
that was unfortunate man
i literally got paid with the person
that don't know anything about
the game that that was unfortunate
could happen that was unfortunate i
don't even know if he knows how to kill
people
or sinister
let's do communications
oh gosh sinister come on
come on sinister
well don't kill anyone there
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do a lights next
if he can't kill anyone with these
lights
come on sister the lights baby
i don't know if he knows how to kill
people
sinister at the bottom right there's a
kill icon you have to hit that on
someone
remove oxygen depletion
oh he might be able to win this if he
kills him
kill him kill her
oh he's definitely done he's done
see if he could convince me what up sin
yeah i saw you oh god
off i saw death my man oh my
god
easy win thank you gg next right
look he's trying to fool you so you're
the last person
accusing the people i see murder oh my
god
hold on no bro damn
what is your name i could have killed
you multiple times what is your name
that's true that's true you were looking
with you the whole
can you tell me what death's name in the
game is oh it's too late
[Music]
also even if you're dead make sure
you're doing your tasks
yeah yeah that's what i meant to tell
y'all when you're dead you still gotta
do your task
oh yeah roaming around doing tasks yeah
like sinister at the beginning you was
like i saw it i'm like
i'm the other imposter what are you
doing
did anybody notice that addict's voice
was about 18
octaves lower this game yeah
i killed everybody but luca yeah he got
me right away
a nice double double take out click on
the bottom right or say return
play again yeah and jw i don't think one
more yeah
just go ahead and start it j i don't
know what happened to j don't let potato
he got it said he got booted
somebody to change anybody without a
beard is sus i'm done
i'm done
reactors at the end let's go get this
storage one first
admin
oh the lights are out i don't like that
i hope king's the imposter man i hope
king's the imposter
king is the imposter
damn dead already i found the dead body
by orange and uh tools
and sus is looking a little sus
those two those two right there
no listen i haven't shut up but i've
been honest with you that wasn't me i
swear to god
and luca knows how i usually defend
myself i'm like what's it me
i promise you most people were walking
around kind of in that area
i wasn't walking around i was on the
cameras i heard jack say don't forget to
do
your tasks so i went right to doing my
homework man i was just running around
doing tests i didn't see
well i didn't say anything
[Music]
i was telling them cameras so uh king
suspect in the mooc i
have a feeling
i missed the first uh segment i skipped
my voting
no it is one of yah it is one of y'all
[Music]
it is tools or or uh incognito you're
dead uh check your facebook real quick
oh my god i need to actually pay
attention
see i actually could do stuff like that
i just i wasn't paying attention
are you sorry about that guys
huh let's see
oh who's this
find the party in storage wonder who's
who's the other impulse standing
i was like what do you do
yeah king was next to me i for a minute
i thought i died
but i didn't so um it just flashed in
front of me i was like i went to the
killer
but then i said okay who do you guys
think the other imposter is i think it's
good
[Music]
you think it's you think it's death i
don't know man i think it's good
mute up task
i don't know who the other imposter is
yet
i have no clue who the other imposter is
to be honest with you
i don't think it's sinister though i
think it's kid smooth
man they getting people up out of there
it's red i saw it on camera whoever read
it
is
red red yeah that's king that that's
king
bro yo i i felt like i was getting
chased by ashley lucas
oh i was behind sinister the whole damn
time nah king because
tools you both had crowns on and two's
left and you were behind me then you
left
and you came back i went back in twos
was that was your pitch move that i was
behind
yeah no i thought it was behind sinister
cause you both got on the hatch
yeah both had all crowds tools was in
the room
uh he left first then you left and then
you came back and when i was
gone towards where y'all went he's dead
so down at the bottom
he's gotta
kid smoothie he needs to be attacking
jack
is this the one person left yo
[Music]
damn it is
we're going to stalk kid smooth all
right because i i believe it's kid
kid is the other imposter
and i'm convinced i don't know i don't
think kid can
can turn the lights off without moving
at the same time so it might not be
kid
so i it's either kid or luca
who do you guys think it is kid or luca
i'm gonna go with my money on kid
because
but kid just threw king under the bus he
should have some kind of protection
jack is uh cut there get him get him get
him
it doesn't matter if he sees you if he's
dead go out there
okay maybe kid's not the imposter
it's lucas
it's got to be luca
it is luca because she missed the first
auction on purpose she went for this one
because this is more out in the open
it's a lot easier to kill people on this
one damn
there's two of them coming luca
she's gonna snap him
is it luca it's one of the man
i'm unsure who it is
okay maybe it is kid he could have
killed jack like six
times
[Music]
kill sinister kill sinister kill
sinister
who is it is it jack
it ma i honestly have no clue who it is
if it's so obvious uh [ __ ] tell me who
it is because i really don't know who it
is
i look you can call me the worst
detective in the world
look a lot of people don't know how to
do the tasks in here so like we're not
going to win from tasks
why would but
why would jack ride out king if he was
the imposter
all right sinister is looking spooky bro
every time i ran
yeah yeah you were there but were you
actually doing it i was doing calms i
was figuring it out
i figured it out in mere seconds
i did it i don't know dude every time
i'm the one who completed it so you look
it's us
i completed it what are you talking
about i was giving i was the one who
made the wings in the same
order no no no no because i did i did
i did you've been in rooms
by yourself and you were camping out
watching me and jack was in security cam
you're camping right out
right in that you camped out you're
trying to see if you're going to murder
somebody
nah no no no no you're waiting for one
of us to get a loan
like that it just really really sucks
right now
help me
and two people can do the tasks at the
same times and you don't yeah they can
financially do
yeah yeah yeah i'm trying to i'm all
right so if y'all
is this sinister bro
not me
uh
maybe it is jack did you guys see him
kill someone
i don't know who it is because i feel
like
jack would have just got him there
that's what i'm saying like because
because there was there's only four so
if they're not there out there if
they're at the other one who is this
that was
jack had the only opportunity to kill me
while i was doing that but uh
exactly who it is i uh i was doing the
oxygen
me and smoove were the only ones if the
ghosts don't do they
have to go here we just gonna be walking
around the circle yeah yeah
i was uh i got stuck on a couple of
walls but
honestly my bubble is still sinister
you're just with me doing
i wasn't i was with luca i was literally
with luca that
i don't know i don't know
i'm telling you down down there hiding
i was just worried you were with me
dummy no i was going through the last
time i accused you this time
somebody was walking with me all the way
from out to me
through the cafeteria through the right
and then down please tell me you voted
thank you you owe me apology
now you you were the imposter
what oh my god it's over
oh hold on it's it's luca
it's luca she about to kill kid smooth
or it's kid smooth i don't know man
kid smooth one of these gotta kill the
other
it's gotta be kids smooth man
because i felt let's look
wow i honestly had
zero recognition you forgot who you were
walking with huh
he
i was
saw luca at the bottom like yeah i got
the jiggy [ __ ] i'm trying to get more
than one
hopefully poke ain't no joke yeah all i
gotta say is that i was
i've been quiet every single match
you're about to lose
and then literally five seconds after i
said that king snaps my neck yeah
yeah you could you could see it live i
did it a lot i was
it was live on the stream because i was
still talking to the chat
that way he would he's like i was behind
well you remember
i mean king was talking quite a bit i
was like king shut up yeah
like you're talking too much dog stop
cake's like why is moose so quiet before
this round meanwhile when i'm quiet i'm
dead because king killed me that's why
i'm quiet
oh that's fine we'll just do one more uh
i honestly didn't know who it was like i
really did not
know who it was
no no no no no when when king when kate
when when luca and i think it was death
were like side by side
and jack and sinister are side by side i
was like luca
and jack have played this game and not
that they would have killed the other
person i would i was
i don't know who it is like i thought it
was luke or sinister i didn't know who
it was though so i
knew it was her from the get-go but he
did yeah and then when i verified
it the one who's following me throws me
under the bus it's like
this move you know shout out to him king
status only
it's crazy go ahead and start it we'll
play woman walking with me and
all like he's walking with me and he's
like nah but it was you
all right
admins hey it's me
i just wanted to come say hi to
everybody and
say happy birthday to addict appreciate
him
[Music]
o2
okay all right well i i don't know i
just saw jack over the dead body but you
know we had that thing with addicts so
i'm not going to vote i went i went
and let that go we were doing our task
everyone doing their tasks though yeah i
went to electricals
at the lights yeah so i'm not voting so
i ain't gonna watch what's up
somebody oh what's up can you still here
yeah i'm here oh i thought you was
getting off
oh yeah you said you said
i appreciate it i'll give you the code
use it one after this guy
oh i don't feel comfortable with this
michi's gonna kill
i feel like it's mooch he sat there he
didn't even
i feel like i should call a meeting
because like mooch sat there he was
pretending like he was doing o2
all right so i found that navigation
room now i want to say
i don't know who the second one is but
i'm pretty sure
mooch was pretending to do o2
no checking a text message but i did do
it
which party did you find addict um
i'm pretty sure i found big cloud and
then only one body
okay and jack was
who's coming thomas is trying to be too
much of an investigation i i'm voting
yeah he's like colombo
uh
all right here you go fam who's the red
that died no name
that was uh i have no clue who that was
no all right tools we gonna let you
chief
y'all really voting people off without
us knowing if it's the person for sure
really we're just going to assume it's
him hey mooch
yeah good job bro jack and luch
i told you
[Laughter]
nice jack i told you i told you guys
whoever voted for me it was it was me
it was fine look can we play one more
game for king because king didn't get to
play a lot let's just play
one more game but like i said i'm down
like i said it doesn't make any sense
all right that you guys were just voting
to be voting jack was like yeah let's do
it i'm like
oh yeah i knew it was just the moment
you said that but
what up king yeah what up back jack
how do you play this game you have to do
that
people when you get a chance yeah i had
i had to float down saying what you said
with me
hey mooch how you doing back from the
dead i see
what's up okay
who said that was that you said that
bitter was that addiction that was me
that was me
that's like i'm checking your text i was
like that's awfully convenient
like yo someone's at the door hold up
it's me and jack move i think this is an
automatic
l for them fix the lights fix the lights
i feel like we can double kill here
because they ain't really doing anything
oh
okay so i reported it saw a sinister
and all i could think i think i saw i'm
not sure that's not a hundred percent
but i thought i saw a king running
past me a second before but that it
might not have been right there
i got no text messages during this whole
time so it was not me i promised you
uh i i think it was king i don't know
where was the body
it was over by the electric uh just
before the corridor before electric
no you never heard him talk about one
word hey listen i swear i'm innocent
people he said sinister i'm not voting
i'm not voting i don't feel like i got
enough
medicine i'm not voting
no i found his body oh man mitch almost
got up out of there it was close
it was stupid all right i'm telling you
it wasn't me
hello wait woman
i'm going to get toys when he comes up
what's a big cloud doing
i gotta get big hollered up out of there
man his hair scares me
all right it's time to get big gallowed
up out of there
let's get them on the right side of the
map so they don't see big clouds
dead body
the moment the moment we were chosen
it was it was a wrap it was a wrap last
one
i have my suspicions all right wait is
he following king and i turn around i
get stabbed again
okay he was following behind me and i
put the dip move on i'm like ah
all right uh i'll catch you boys later
happy birthday adam yeah happy birthday
addict i gotta bounce dude was good
playing with you guys
all right gigi's guest moment me and
jack was chosen as your opponents it was
a rat
like you already know you already know
we had to get them up out of there
what's funny is i i i was originally
gonna uh gonna get one to go up to
to oxygen and then kill one up there and
then would you showed us
let's just double kill them it's just in
this
you got anyone else they can join uh
joke no i don't think so
yeah everyone asleep yeah
i think that's it for me i appreciate
you guys coming on it was it was a fun
time
thank you how much was the game
happening
that was my first steam purchase and
that was because of you happy birthday
i told you the game's fun the game's fun
when you get it it's gonna be
even more fun when we got that on 90
bucks
it was five bucks but in game pass it'd
be free
oh god is it in game fast and they
disconnected
not yet
catch you guys later man y'all have a
blessed man enjoy your birthday brother
yo you got some latest
luca early because she she will you know
be trying to investigate
people believe that i was with them
so that's why i had to kill luca early
yes sir
i killed i killed big cloud because his
hair scared me
yeah you got to get like big cloud luca
you know they've been playing so they
know what's going on
you can't even see me in the stream
because i didn't have enough uh i didn't
have a kill
at the time and uh i i literally
i i went into med bay faked med bay fake
scared and then i was like i got i got
my kill cam man
i'm about to go kill big cloud and when
i went up big cloud was going the other
way
i'm surprised i didn't get off
i was looking for you yo i ran past you
a few times
i know i know that's where i've
started running around in circles
because i had a suspicion so i just
i went up the middle of the map and then
just carried on around navigation i went
around like four times
the english guy doesn't die in the
movies
i play on my other computer too so how
many computers you got now
uh two
did you play that new fall guys no not
yet i got you though
do you got that on pc nah
that's where everyone plays it's pc
when's the update for this
among us i don't i thought we i was
hoping we'd have the new map sooner
they said next year yeah make sure i
think early next year
so i want to be able to select where you
start after the meeting
they'll make killing people easier
because whoever you want to kill you
just select the same room as them
the cooldown will have to be made high
on that map like 35
40 seconds well there's also moving
parts as well like that one platform
that goes back and forth
there was that one level that had like a
basement like three levels
to it yeah you go up and down the map i
mean
you have to climb up and down ladders
what i wonder if you could kill someone
on the ladder
the ladder i don't know you kill them or
they just fall down to the bottom of the
ladder
yeah that map looks like it's going to
be spooky
i'm 29 29. yeah
you're nearly a big three becoming a man
did you think i was in like my mid-30s
or something
not that he was like going to be or 30
this year or something no i'm 20.
yeah people think i'm a lot older than i
really am
it's the hair man it's the beard yeah it
definitely is the beard
it does aid you people think i'm a lot
younger than i really am
all right so go figure
i'm late i'll be 30 minutes oh
my gosh people people asking me look
i'll be 35. see but like look i i'll
give you guys one thing
the chat's like the chat wants me to
play and put the code public
you saw what happens when i put the code
public all right like
people are some crazy crazy individuals
and like let's say that i do make the
code public and we do play a game like
maybe through chat
or or the discord like
because you're gonna you're gonna come
through the stream through my stream so
you guys are all gonna stream tonight
i'm not saying all of you but there's
gonna be at least one of you that stream
tonight
yeah that makes it better man
king enjoyed it i i knew king would like
that game after he uh
tried it out it's it screams king's kind
of game
straight up man to people for no reason
jack move i got i had i had jack move
numbers there man i had like 15 almost 2
000 people
viewers yeah i saw it like a thousand
congrats man it was a sub
i i think what it is is i i think you
get the algorithm
and it just goes up but it it went up
pretty fast it went down pretty fast
yeah so things been broken even
notifications
look man the world of crafts i i don't
know you like that my my dude
like i don't know you like that like
it's like i said
it wouldn't be the same man like it
might be the same
yeah yeah i got rogue
i play rogue uh i don't know y'all
did i didn't write it hold up
addy i mean i had a gum that's right you
won't bust a rope
did i delete rogue i probably could grab
some food and i also deleted rogue so
i'd have to re-download it anyway
oh why'd you delete rogue because i
needed to make room for psycho cyberpunk
oh that worked out well for you oh it
did that's a great trade
that's that's that's a trade up nothing
like nine witches i might stream
something else anthony just give me a
second
because i was like yeah no one's ready
to play a road company it's just taking
up useless space
actually big cloud you you want to play
the new update for fall guys
uh is it out for bc yet yeah
came out like two days ago i'm gonna at
least try it i'm gonna play a couple
yeah
uh do you have um fall guys on pc
yeah that's what we've got to jump on
because everyone got off
okay sound good to me i have yet tried
this out but
i'm curious did you play the the season
twos
things nah i left like season two had
some fun games had some fun games i'll
be right back let me go get this
i have to go get a a cord so i can hook
up my controller
oh there's my hands outside on this
thing too i didn't know they did that
okay that's it so far so good
there we go
confirmed it from the pre-alpha back for
blood is left for death three in
everything but name
which we predicted it was so
there we go
oh wow they let you put your name back
in here
hold on no no never mind what
no i thought they you know on statement
you couldn't like enter your own name
man
oh i had no clue okay steven finally
updated for doing something
that's what's up yeah no that was just
saying that they
took people off because the names were
too offensive i guess oh they finally
fixed that
yeah but i can't change my name i'm not
something that's red but they
just put up i might have misread
probably gonna have an update
i'm gonna jump i'll come back and see
something
see now we don't need this image because
people ain't gonna say some
some nonsense
some of these games in this um
i don't know how many new maps they have
i'm sure it's like ice related too
it's gonna a lot of it is apparently
it's eight new modes from what
was telling me that on twitter yesterday
cuz i played for a little bit
ps4 that's interesting
let me
i actually really enjoyed this game i
just felt i wish they would update
[Music]
[Music]
window on
there you go
[Music]
all right
[ __ ]
man
[Music]
oh such friends
stream to get on my nerves man
[Music]
this team be getting on my nerves
all right can i hear you know yeah yes
sir all right
um what's your code uh
your your friend code yeah i can hear
you
oh in the game i have no
[Music]
they asking for mom but i don't even
know where to find that hold up go to
your um
profile so your profile let me jump out
of this right quick
um say a profile yeah it should be
profile
if you can't see it go to where it says
friends underneath profile
and then go to add friend and then it'll
show your code
right there what
friends me say a friend no it should
just be in your profile
okay so i'll check here first
go to like the actual hub like the
actual app
first team it's a lot easier to find on
that
wait is that on my phone let's see let's
see if it's on my phone
ah no well let me use my doing something
damn it
now that's
i thought it was going to work for a
second do you have him on steam but
yeah just send me an invite
here uh here's mine
here [ __ ] there's my friend code
i got you one second
yeah we we've switched to to
to fall guys i actually really really
like this game
one second let me uh get my other
controller
[Music]
is your steam connected to your uh
discord
my steam no um nah i didn't know you
well i knew you can do it i just i don't
think i've ever done it
there i think you can just search their
during a while and too late hey try let
me go pay 60 frames i guess maybe i
don't need it though
this is why i don't like using steam it
it's definitely
a little bit more too frustrating than
it should be i should be able to just
look up their name but it doesn't look
like it works like
that
but the catch with it is a little too
random
fall guys is random it i guess it just
depends on what map you play like i
don't like the
grab the tail ones i don't like any of
those they actually did add a couple fun
maps in the last season and i'm assuming
there's new maps in this season
but i haven't played any of them as you
can see i'm level one
there's one new one for sure for sure um
all higher than level one
it's like a race to the finish that
one's just pretty good too
yeah i actually enjoy playing fall guys
by myself
like i can play fall guards by myself
it's definitely a lot better with
friends
now you can play by yourself
i always thought the season pass stuff
was just whacked though i've never liked
the season
hey eddie gotta show me how to connect
my
suspender oh that's your pen name my
fault
i said you gotta show me how to connect
all this when i'm you know
playing the game oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
let me show you guys online you guys on
my screen
uh i thought that was when you played uh
what was that
um
[Music]
before that when he was trying what's
your code
uh my code is
she sent it to me on discord just put it
up here
well then yeah let me jump out i'll find
my my code right quick you said it was
in profile right
right yeah all you have to do is just go
to uh to
your your actual steam app go up to
friends
add add a friend and it'll be the first
thing that pops up
did you put it in the general chat
and then invites hold on so it's no
problem are you ready you ready
yeah yeah oh man four three nine
364.
there you should have got mine
caught us right here now i got you
what's your code um
hustle i'm about to send it to you
somebody's talking to you right now
[ __ ]
assuming i'm that blind hold on wait a
minute
we're not we're not we're not we're not
gonna make this harder than what it is
if you want look uh look at the stream
i'll show you how to get to it i
already have it okay no i'm just trying
to
say it out just say it all out okay
four seven three okay four seven
three one one one zero
zero uh-huh 207 207.
huffle and motif got you i just got you
that's that's more complicated than what
it needed to be that's what i'm saying
but it
[Music]
i relaunched this game again on it
because i closed
[Music]
invite to play the game
yeah i'm trying to get this on camera i
got my display just play cable
man i had it at 120 at first i don't
know what happened for what [ __ ]
yeah um i need all that joint to be
right yeah
[Music]
play games at 60 because i have to
yeah the highest you can get season one
i think was 40.
i think they're all for even for season
two and three
yeah i thought they got rid of that
that's weird
yeah there we go
why do i check this
[Music]
[Music]
it pops man it really does pop
shout out to everybody in the stream yo
305 in the building
oh wait y'all waiting on me oh yeah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey you want to jump in mercury
wait is that my name now yeah it is
these are our names now
let's see two people but i hear 10
voices all right
are you watching the the beginning stuff
oh oh just go ahead and start it now
he's in here
mark's in the chat i mean oh i didn't
know if mark wants to play
no he said he's working uh okay
like i see what they changed names to
right yeah you can
generate a random name now
if i can't do it it won't let you use
real names because you know
strange snipers
don't want to hear what the audio
i mean there's not 10 people in the chat
talking
what's he talking about
all right man let me see if i can get a
w i came close yesterday
i don't know what you're uh what you're
hearing you know yo
what are you listening to let me just
put a screen
i guess i'll record a bit of this
um
[Music]
and they're gonna start at 40.
[Music]
okay it's not as hyped as it was last
time
[Music]
it took me a little while to get into uh
what was that um getting game on ps5 too
how was it yeah it didn't take this long
it didn't take this long but
it took a little while they're probably
upgraded nervous i mean
the game just became another you know
huge hit for him
i just hope they don't have skill based
matchmaking that's going to just kill
[Music]
it literally is the first one that i
can't do i hate this one with the
passion
[Applause]
oh whoa okay
everybody else saw that too right
the wrong piece you don't put it
going right
there we go
there you go
[Music]
we all qualified at least oh no if i
wouldn't qualify i got a game on
i'm the secret yellow dude
secret yellow dude
i would prefer us to be boss before
these random names
[Music]
yeah a lot of these matches i wanted to
try i just i hadn't played it
since season one
oh gosh tundra run navigate the
crosstalk i was going to race to the
finish line
that's what i played yesterday what is
it like um
springs i think this is a new one isn't
it this is like a
slime it's kind of like that i i might i
like low-key
i i might fail this like this looks
intimidating i might feel this
is that ice yeah that's nice jesus
christ
can i like slide that did you ever see
that show ninja warrior
yeah yeah i used to watch them
oh i got hit by a snowball are we out
there wow
wow it's joining legs
oh it's the ice it's the ice for me
let's go okay
i'm about to get eliminated man
[Music]
oh it's this wind
i feel like i let everyone down let me
in
let me in
[Music]
what did you do
something wrong with the game they
didn't stop me at that last checkpoint
it stopped me at the beginning dude
did you get it no it was talking to me
at the beginning i was at the end
and i fell and it started me at the
beginning yeah
oh
[Music]
i'm starting to think that uh that
hustle did some shady stuff
to get us out of that game man look i
can't even get back to my
cable i'm also done
also does my curse
you gotta connect let it fall guys
that's some [ __ ] you got to connect
man you got to connect
look look anthony talking about me
almost losing we ain't talking about
that
you know what we talking about yeah d
we lost everyone uh dxx
i don't even know how to change the name
to be honest with you
oh you go to um when you're using obs
are you
you see how it says live uh your little
live um thing
on youtube did you say live
uh edit yeah
okay yeah just change it there
all right so at least we oh this again
we get redemption
yeah we just started back i didn't need
redemption i i didn't lose
i already wanted
that was a cool map though that's pretty
cool i like that
i wasn't expecting like uh boxing gloves
to come on left field though
yeah now we get the frosty obviously
erase this finish line
you got to use the wind as an advantage
too like that
it should have changed the name refresh
refresh
and tell me if it worked if it didn't
you got going obs you ain't
with me man you got to blame it knock up
guys with the crew right
[Music]
[Applause]
get off me though grab it grab that
look how close we are to each other i
don't like this i feel populated
i'm getting them up out of here oh yeah
let's go
yeah i have a feeling going left to
rights better than going in that middle
oh it definitely is
oh that wind i hate it
alright cool there we go
oh my gosh man i hate this game i hate
it got it
let's go
[Applause]
to the other ramp just as it was going
to launch the
secret yellow dude is going to the
second round that's all that matters
this is not a laggy logo i know right
yeah that's one thing i don't remember
about this game usually
like there's no lie yeah the lag was
fine
people trying to cheat that's what it is
oh and i remember the hackers were in
the flying hackers
oh on the map
oh god it's all downhill let's go
okay i'm interested in this way do you
have
[Applause]
oh wow you have to do that
oh you have to get 15 to do it
[Music]
oh you have to keep doing it over and
over again until you get 15.
i completely just dropped the ball there
man
wow wow they keep knocking me off i hate
these people
[Applause]
oh wow
oh my god i'm not gonna qualify i got
seven
seven out of 15. i'm literally not gonna
qualify
i'm a big trash
that is so dumb
[Music]
all right i'm okay with that i'm okay
that's my first time playing i'm okay
with that
i got three man i pulled it off
i'm okay with that i'm thinking the the
bull's-eye the middle counts for how
many points
like i don't know man this got a lot of
new games
that caught me yesterday
freezy skeleton mountain reached the
finish line
this is dope i like how they got
creative with the mouse yeah they're
really creative
i can't even how many oh geez that's
really cool how many people are there 15
so this the
nah i say the one i don't think
[Music]
oh he survived lucky
[Applause]
so you know you can jump into it
i actually i lowkey mess with this
yeah you guys can have that that's all
yours
oh wow this is this is the lap that was
pretty cool
you guys can't second doubt me man
guys this this should be uh it right
unless you're doing like an elimination
one i doubt it though
man okay this
thing they changed up they changed up a
whole lot i give them that
now between you know don't leg
no cheating that's all that matters man
we we in the wild wild west that
would be a lot of cheating dude grab
what what does it say
grab and hold a penguin to score teams
for your team
to score
this is my penguin now it's my thing
give me that
oh they're rough oh yeah look at him
already with my penguin
hey teammates who grabbed you more my
penguin
no i really do i hate that i hate when
teammates grab me more than the enemy
man you guys should have that thing
so you better score his son
is it just the one it's a pain
right past it though
[Music]
someone grab that yellow dude don't let
him grow
oh my god are you grabbing your teammate
i didn't mean to it was an accident
oh no yo y'all getting going
gross your teammates grabbing you this
ain't working
so we'll grab that penguin
grab that penguin all right
grab that penguin you got it you got it
you got it but y'all
y'all far behind okay yeah grab that
penguin
grab yellow don't let him grab that one
yeah get that red guy put some pressure
on him
yo everybody have 100 points
[Music]
my penguin get off me it's my thing
i turned that around just in the naked
time
all right daddy now you gotta win you
gotta win it's your birthday sir
dude i get any kind of handicap
what the handicap is [ __ ] not
flying across the map anymore that's the
handicap
yeah that's definitely man that's fast
i don't think they solved the problem
i'm pretty sure there's still some hacks
or she's going up
then ice crackling nice to avoid the
slime below
okay so that so it's the same thing as
hexagon yeah but i feel like you could
sound them a little longer because it
just cracks a little over time i don't
know maybe it
i don't know oh
okay maybe maybe not maybe it's okay so
it's different layers to it
so if you get stuck on like if one if
one goes down a couple
it's over yeah because you're not gonna
be able to jump back up
oh quick it's breaking wow okay guess
where it goes
i don't like you guys oh this is about
to get bad
oh
don't get too crazy watch your steps
oh what's up chris
[Music]
all right everybody back up look the
lords aren't playing
it's it's my friends playing we were
playing fall guys though we're playing
fall guys
being among us yeah among us
[Music]
it was definitely kind of fast
considering when i got knocked out
[Music]
well you can't even why did you get that
right every time
[Music]
not showing you on my screen all right
hold up let me just leave and
come back
did you
it's leave pc okay
yeah christopher i actually i really
enjoyed the new games in here it gives
you more variety
because it was it was looking a little
spooky for this game when this game
first came out
yeah they were real bare bones not much
they got repetitive really really fast
because small weren't dumb they did them
all with the eggs
oh wow they finally put on online monkey
player for um
sack boys big adventure
it took them a little while but it's in
there now
oh it's today okay
but king and car actually enjoyed a
manga so we might actually play that
more often
oh we knew king was going to enjoy it
for the longest you're trying to try to
just like go oh
it's gotta be game fast mike king you're
gonna like they do need to put that on
all consoles though there's no reason
it's only for the switch
it needs to be on all consoles with
cross play
yeah switching pc and phones yeah that's
weird
like imagine cross play with that
proximity chat that's on pc
oh wait they had approximately
okay and it's not that long like
proximity chat is not that big
yeah yeah it's just you know who you
pass and yeah nice all right
this one's all the maps i should should
do fairly well on this one too
assuming you know watch me fail
i'm going for that i'm going for that
middle one i'm gonna jump
oh i missed it i missed it
are you serious
wow are you ever going to come down
thank you
i definitely felt this you're almost
finished first
dove and still missed him
[Music]
don't worry i ain't making man
i tried because i i i sat behind a gate
too long because i thought it was going
to come back down sooner than it did
yeah like
i think it's on the second row or third
row
yeah it doesn't come back though if
someone's gonna end again they don't
that's like that's wrong when you bought
it
they get all their money from cosmetics
pretty much
there's rocket league all over here wait
they shooting stuff at us this time
around
i'm actually glad i'm dead
yo yo oh wow
oh the blueberries are deadly
the blueberries are deadly
it's like they took the um it's like
they took the easiest maps and they're
like okay you guys talking [ __ ] all
right we
they saw everybody doing the doing the
med strat where you go to the bathroom
and don't come up
don't learn
oh you're about to die
was that everyone that was me
did you follow a bit yeah all right good
we can leave
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't like see that's my issue with
the xbox right now like
not only did they miss out on fall guys
they missed out on among us too
they really did they let they let
nintendo switch come in there
and jack everything up let me finally
double the points because it's christmas
time i noticed that yeah i noticed that
too i hit level five
first one i leveled up like eight times
when i got you i was in the mother on
everything like it's not even a big game
it's not hard to port i think i think
nintendo paid
something i mean like
that's like the perfect game for like
the switch because of what it is
you played them demonstration bro i got
one trophy and this choke bro
i want to smack a developer
pretty much you got to get pure white
character tendency
um to get one ring to get this ring and
yo
i did i followed this thing online on
how to get it i did
everything and i still don't have two
white characters
you can kill me and get your characters
your way right
huh yeah yeah that's i was hitting that
blaze i was like blaze
let's connect let me kill you and let me
like fix my character tennessee because
you could do it that way
yeah because it decided ring
so let me kill you
yeah i can i can fire it back up i just
gotta download it
all right just yeah i got it it'll take
it won't take long
just let me know
don't start oh did you use the trick i
don't know if he told you about the gold
coin
like a gold coin um that like basically
when you use the gold coin i think it
increases your luck stack which might
not either your luck or
something but um it basically when you
combine that with ad storage
you one hit all bosses
[Applause]
oh i barely got in there but i got in
there it's all that matters
uh i'm ahead man i'm head where are you
guys at the other ring to them [ __ ] i'm
all the way back here
i'm gonna try the middle one because i
did so well i'm gonna try the middle one
i really get the middle one but i'm
gonna try it
yeah see that that's the [ __ ]
happening we are back here sir
stupid green dinosaur
[Music]
mouse does this thing where it double
click sometimes
[Applause]
all right oh did you get um metastatic
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
you guys still alive or it's just me no
i'm in here
at it yeah i'm here okay
now saying who's still alive
i got lucky and made it but this oh
oh boy
actually you're pretty good at this
uh like taking forever to load now you
know
i don't know it's probably because they
put more maintenance in their servers
now
as long as they stop cheaters i don't
care what they do
great watermelon
yeah it only starts for two
i didn't know i just want you ever had
the most likely the lie there
great cherries grape cherries
grape cherries watermelon banana grape
cherries watermelon banana
grape cherries watermelon someone pick
me up
don't grab me you boy there you go i
hate crap
i know is that one of them okay apple
okay
jerry i'm so screwed
can't let these people grab me and throw
me off
yeah perfect show again we played for a
while but the lords actually really
liked
among us so we'll probably play that
again i could see that happening now see
see sometimes i had to i had to itch the
itch them onto the platform and get them
to try the game out
next next is uh fall guys but i don't
think i'm going to get that taken care
of
i don't think that's happened but uh
king was definitely enjoying a manga so
i think we'll be playing that more often
oh
[Laughter]
okay here we go we're back here again so
now i know what the hell i'm doing so
now
it should be i'm trying to figure out
how to help you get up in the middle
like that
i guess you gotta use one of them launch
pads to do that you can just go all the
way down so if you miss one you just go
to the next one
and it'll restart you at the beginning
that's good
for that one that was right i'll miss
the second one no i didn't
uh damn
oh wow wow okay
get that gold let's go
oh i got silver i got seven out of 15
little boys
i fell off oh that's how okay it's okay
okay
okay now now i get it and you can keep
going
let me get this over here
i need two more
we could just we could just jump off and
get that last one real quick
there we go done over with
are we in there boys oh no yeah
damn i missed the last three
i didn't know you can keep going like
that
anybody can get in my way
[Music]
it's one of the new stages christopher
did everyone get through nah i missed by
five
you gotta get those silvers man those
silvers
you got dudes like jumping at the same
time
oh fancy peak did you get through muscle
puzzle yes i did
awesome we i get to do this i actually
like this this is my favorite new map
i thought it was the ending map for a
second but it's not i think this could
be an ending
you put in the middle right there you
put the um the
like the ground in the middle
i'm over here by myself i'm cool with
that and i wasn't by myself and that's
oh oh geez okay crap cheese let's go
i'm not scared i ain't scared
let's go
okay
like little kid at black friday
[Applause]
they put you far back man yeah they do
it might be a rat for me don't worry man
it's going to be right for both of us
yeah thanks for breathing that's right
i got this i got this watch oh man
i got this never mind
i don't got this i don't got this and
hustle's done okay
all right i didn't know i had to go up i
thought i had to run around all right
everybody all right okay
all right i'm gonna get a double before
i get up over here i know that it's that
corner man that corner is deadly man
that quarter with the
man okay let's let's let's just take
into account
the the bull that was around that corner
you have the gloves that's on the the
right you jumping onto
[Music]
who me that's not on bg
what's up you jumping on [ __ ] yes sir
oh it's not
more
cheese
no meds i like all the dope outfits
how many ways did he get a lot
meds was definitely probably the best
person all right so
so let let's let's recap that one so
because my brother came here and
interrupted me so
you got the boxing gloves on the right
that's hitting you and then you got the
thing that pops out in the middle
and on the left there's the snowball
it's like
yeah yeah there's nowhere to go it's
like you have to take which one you can
let it go you were you were missed you
were missing it so you had to get past
the boston box
and wait for the second hit on the other
one
i think the easiest one would be to take
the snowball one and just go between the
little bouncing things between them
i wouldn't even say that because
remember the bounce these just don't
knock you off
but i mean but there's a good amount
that's that good amount of distance
between them though
true but you know how these uh fall guys
characters out when they get by
a snowball i know right i went where
she's getting
i spawn right in two of them snowball
too they
gate crash i think i think that this
this is my kryptonite earlier one
it should be easy w for me right here
just it better be
announcement they're doing on the 12th
now what's up they're doing like a
showcase on the 12.
oh no okay i'm waiting on that 38 yeah
because i'm
i was one upgrade when i was going to 30
80 but
like i spent a little bit 38 ti yeah
i got 751 supplies should be
good i know right yeah that's
the other thing
i'm jumping this i'm jumping this told
you i was gonna make that
all future upgrades are postponed before
probably
mid-2021 yeah that's the that's the gate
that screwed me up last time
thank you wow i was the fourth person
come on
stupid hot dog
yeah just stay straight there you go you
got
clouds you might be right yet i think
they did uh like double the points
because
like i said i got to like the final one
they only think i was at the final round
but i know i went from level one to
level five like
super quick
they made those points worthwhile oh
okay you know they just doubled it
because of the holiday yeah one of those
like double xp week or something
oh dizzy heights
probably the most straightforward map
yeah they do need to bring back one
versus 100
i think we've said that for so long
though we know that ain't happening
one versus 100 you don't remember that
forgot about that yeah that
go with the yo
look at the balls are different colors
now
that's fine
what is that
oh mallet that's funny i was trying to
get it
oh that's the big you just update
i need to stop trying to get hit by that
yeah that was a part of our last season
he tried to grab me around right into
the wall
ah that was funny i got eliminated
i was dude i was playing too much
well else got eliminated oh no i'm still
here i got i got hit by
i was trying to get hit by that mallet i
don't know why
i don't know i know he's trying to be
fancy
i don't think there's any guarantee it
knocks you all the way over there anyone
like
you know over the obstacle well it's
definitely going to knock me closer to
not hitting them
lauren's daddy win the race
all right i played this one yesterday
swap
i don't know if they integrate more than
move games
trying to grab you that's the only oh oh
yeah
watch if i change this they changed it
i said that right well this is
hey you're trying to grab me guys
[Laughter]
all right doing this
he's gonna get eliminated
which one are you uh
who's snowflake
that's me yo
did you get eliminated yeah i got pushed
over
like literally i'm like
[Laughter]
no duke
gotta take me one of them fell
ball ball huh i hate this one i wish
they'd take this out
glad i don't fire man you just need to
be with him
but you got idiots who just like to grab
people that's you're not gonna do it
no they need to take this out
i mean all the team oh wow oh you know
the thing now
oh yeah you know why they put teams in
here anyway right
so when people like masses and lots of
people don't get eliminated
no it's hackers so hackers can get by
uh i mean that was the year before the
hacking started
i'm saying like hackers can't get past
this level wow they had the little ball
thing
too you know oh sorry
all right no
yeah i feel like low-key this got a
little bit better with these adjustments
oh we just got screwed no we did not
oh yeah okay
there you go you like that
[Music]
change the music and all that fire
[Music]
i still can't believe i completely
dropped the ball that much on luke when
we was playing them
i guess i said like it's so obvious who
it is
no no no i'm talking about what i
accused luca
well she said he said if you're wrong
you better apologize
to god damn right like go back and look
at that like
i saw luca over a dead body what else
was i supposed to think
like
i barely hit that but it was enough to
get into right now i'm probably gonna
clip that make that on twitter
that dude gave up that two gave up did
you win let's go
yeah oh this is the last one
giggling star that's funny i wonder what
this could be
last five years i'll be right back just
go straight up the map
yeah it seems like they've been
favoriting the new maps over the old
ones
jump shots i wonder if they change this
at all
i know the platforms disappear that's
about platforms disappear
disappeared um they move a lot those
things move a little faster too
yeah christopher i'm definitely gonna
i'm very interested in the dual
uh sense controller i am yeah i was
trying to play
uh this with it earlier
[Applause]
okay
what up with that i got no
business talk of that i got eliminated
matterly
[Music]
oh
saturday morning though
i was supposed to work yesterday but uh
i thought the snow was gonna be way
worse than it was so i called in
oh yeah you know i try to go on my girl
no i would have won it well i can't i
can't i can't argue with you on that
because i woke up
and i saw him and i saw there was no
snow on the ground
and i definitely wasn't reaching for my
phone to volunteer to go to
well work yes i be when it's my birthday
and awesome i ain't going to work
sit back this is like
something i can't avoid that then i have
to go
so i don't know about you i kind of like
the winner over there
i got to start working on the show this
sunday
what are you trying to get on this week
we're doing like a
a generation podcast it's going to be
dedicated to the whole generation of
games
it's nice okay i got it
[Music]
it's going to be different like unless
something like drastically happens
between now and sunday
there's not really going to be any like
general topics
you know what i'm saying um
like moments of the year etc etc
what's up anthony you get the day off
that's always a nice thing
i hate that last part with that ice man
i hate that part
yeah yo i didn't realize today was the
17th like on christmas next week
i don't know where the time went like i
don't know i don't know where the time
is going
it ain't been going to us this uh this
month went by fast
and the funny thing is i already spoiled
myself yeah
much better you think about it bought
the ps5 got my 4k money
oh
no i ain't doing that i've learned i've
learned my
my my ways gotta go around man can't go
over gotta go around
i feel like that is so inconsistent man
what is the ramp the the little thing
that like throws you
oh yeah
there we go oh why'd i do that it's not
gonna knock you
out come on they did all dirty
they definitely did
this over here trying to grab you on the
on the jump like what is he doing
oh
he was about to land he was good did any
of y'all make it
i mean i made it all right i was i was
like third or fourth
i finished uh i'll record this last
little bit let me get the hell about oh
i'm john man
i'm a little heated behind that oh it's
it's fine man i doubt right there you
know like
i can't i can't i can't roll okay okay
you can't quit because it's just one
little incident
now i had three i'm trying to work on um
not that i'm stranded what's the name of
that damn video
um twitch allow you to update um i'm
sorry stream in 4k let's let's play one
more after this one more
nope all right i think i got it no you
can't stream before kill twitch i think
it'll it'll come
but like i don't know i don't stream
like that
which i've always considered picking up
streaming
more yeah because i like doing videos
but
it's just like i like streaming too it's
hard to do both
depends on the game returning
what's the name of that one the um
callisto
protocol yes what's called
is creepy
video rgt put up a video and then the
title he got a mario 3d all stars
disappearing
i'm about to flip their drinks i still
got my joint in package
selling that oh no i'm definitely going
to sell it
don't blame me blame nintendo
nintendo nintendo the only company that
could sell you a game
at full price five years after the game
was stolen
no one had no enhancers no updates no
nothing exactly
and dudes with damage controller well
that's nintendo nintendo's your own
company
i'll laugh all right here we go
right
[Music]
no
y'all missed that uh i missed that
messenger outfit man i should i know i
should play this ring last season
come on come on come on
look at this dude
[Music]
though they like was like uh just like
in his video until oblivious
oh this one with 15 000 views on it
oh no no
are you lost okay okay
i don't like the enthusiasm that you
have because i lost
yeah i gotta make it to them man
let's go
got 13 people it's a lot of people
oh this is going to be rough man
i think i may know somebody
oh man everybody's so close
i i don't think there should be that
many people for that it really should
that's what threw me off like god it's a
lot of people on this last one
[Applause]
damn i almost had it too
i'm watching this whole thing it's
almost over it's over now
[Music]
oh
okay you know i just let the whole thing
finish out because we're still busting
there
chop up some of this footage later i
guess well cd projekt red been in the
bushes the moment
they delayed the game last time a week
before
lunch
i'm sorry
and the dudes who put them on this
pedestal because of one game and you
know that it was
uh oh you know who that was also
dude
though man i was watching the shootout i
was just so happy because i'm
one of the homies at level 1 it was like
hey don't hop in the car just walk
around so i'm walking around
i see a little rival gang shootout dude
was getting shot in his head he did not
drop
he was eating them joints i said okay
because you know it
it reminded me like grand theft auto 5
like well normally when you see stuff
like that somebody died at that point
it's over yeah it's just this one went
over
i said i should have recorded it but i
was up there for like a good like five
minutes
that's gotta be awkward for um holly
bennett too because holly bennett left
playstation for cd pleasure right
should be all right you know it's all
like playstation axis yeah oh yeah no i
know you come up
i'm not super she's gonna be good though
it ain't
she's still on twitter a few days she'll
be all right i mean on the bright side
at least she got to make a game i came
in front she made a game
because uh what's couldn't make a game
what's your name amy hennig she stars
oh boy but what was um i thought she was
just like one of the pr people like one
of the faces like
of it um probably better
because i know she would do the uh what
are they calling things she wants
to cat man i don't know got to i mean go
to the storm busting catnip why are you
in my chat asking for catnip
oh yo i mean you know wow i mean maybe
she means something
maybe yeah
[Applause]
oh wow okay
oh that's much easier do i care wait i
cannot see
okay
wow i'm definitely going that way
unless there's an achievement to go up
in there
all right cool
let's go that's what i was trying to do
the last time man
you got that redemption man you got the
same map and everything
everybody made it yeah i got it
[Applause]
oh code veins on game pass
my radar yeah it did too
did it just now launch
don't forget all about kobe i wonder if
um
what is it
i wanna put hey i wonder if it's on
steam it probably is and i won't see if
it's on sale
[Applause]
that was funny they all jumped at the
same time
i missed the door come on in there
they got over them got it i'm into
all right you didn't make it nah i got
it
okay cool i want to say i got in there
before i edited
it i got there like the top ten
[ __ ] i was one of the last people to
make it
all right
i hate this one this is this is where
it's a wrap for me
don't dive that's all you gotta do is
don't don't jump in oh yeah that's
great advice that's great advice no you
jump down you're done
you're gonna fall i'm running up the
side anyway i'm glad they started me
over to the
left oh my man
i can't stand this watermelon apple
cherry
[ __ ] let's go
oh my god come on y'all move all the way
oh they get lit they're getting lit
let's go
let's go yeah it's a wrap it's a wrap
for me i'm not even on the conveyor belt
that's right sir that's right good sir
appreciate you
lock him up oh wait oh i gotta hurry up
yeah
i finally got on the conveyor belt it's
a wrap
okay let me see if i can make it i don't
know what i mean
now whopping
the last little thing screwed me over i
was at the almost the end of the
conveyor belt
told you guys i was getting eliminated
yeah yeah knocked out yeah
i was one of the last people go let's go
what's your name
uh well i'll give you my name
yeah it should go um your camera should
go straight to me when um
when the game starts team game
oh hopefully i'm not yellow because
he'll watch you be yellow. i know right
watch outside the game this oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i said wheels in there let's go you know
they're salty no they salty
that's funny all right this should be it
then 12. see if i can get this w
yeah that's the last one
let's go let's go hustle hustle got this
hustle yeah
i better have it
i still haven't seen that map yet with
the spiky little thing
and then i don't know what that was okay
also have you done this one yet no
first time i mean it's kind of like
hexagon but if you're being real but
this one's a little bit more uh
move away well it can be it can be more
uh chaotic than hexagon to be honest
because usually you're nowhere near
people late game in hexagon and like
you're still right next to them in this
one
all right i'm gonna break all these top
joints you know
trouble
though let's break these
i think he's just breaking all the top
ones besides the last one because he
wants people to fall on it they can they
secure
yes that actually would make the most
sense just sit on one of them until they
all break
and jump on the next one instead of
running like this
nah i gotta run like this i gotta keep
moving i can see i usually backfire
because all it takes is one smart player
to know um
the route and like track you in and
you're not going anywhere
all right oh you're on the last way one
oh my god
six all right
let me see if we can there we go
ah oh all right all right
now i could have been better that's okay
that's all right
all right i mean we did that
i joined ain't gonna see the light of
day i'll tell you i don't mind anyway
level up like that what's going on all
right
all right y'all look i'm out attic happy
birthday man
whatever whatever it is you can try to
go doing the pandemic try to go
do something man try to try to get out
the house or something man but
that's been a pleasure all right you
guys have a good day